hi dr. chu hey Whitney how are you thank
you for being with us today I'm good
thank you so much for having me on you
know I I'm store that you're working
around the clock these days so it really
it means a lot that you took some time
to be with us and you know I think I I
asked how you are but I would love to
hear you know truly like how are our
things going how are you making out in
these times yeah I mean I personally
can't complain you know Oregon is not
New York right now we've actually taken
a lot of early public health measures
and are being pretty successful at
flattening the curve so certainly I mean
we're seeing cases it is a time like no
other in healthcare I mean really
experienced nothing like this it is you
know I'm part of this kind of big
community of frontline health care
workers and talking to my friends around
the country and around the world really
who are in the emergency room or or are
working in the intensive care units and
it it is an incredibly stressful time as
a whole but but here in Oregon we're
lucky to still be waiting for the wave
to hit us and and you you know mention
this at Oregon is not has not been hit
as hard as some other states but I guess
could you talk a little bit more about
what you were saying there with Oregon
flattening the curve and tell us a
little bit more about what the situation
looks like there and then also in your
hospital specifically yeah I mean the
the first case in the United States of
course came to Seattle which is just
three and a half hours up the road as it
happened it came the first case that was
detected was someone who works at the
school were my that my kids attend which
is one block from my house so when it
came to Oregon it started feeling real
very quickly and then early on we saw
the pattern that we were seeing across
the United States I mean the doubling
times here were every two and a half to
three days
and I think between watching what was
happening in Seattle where the case has
really exploded we we took our
stay-at-home order very seriously you
know so schools were shut down pretty
early on people have really been trying
to abide by stay-at-home recommendations
and and we we watched that doubling time
start to stretch out and the progressed
the projections for what our hospitals
would see for our needs for bed space
for intensive care unit base and for
ventilators started going down until
until you could see that probably we
will be within the resources that we
have in our state
which is wonderful and earlier this week
you know Oregon was able to to clench to
send 140 ventilators to New York City
there try to help them meet the need in
this time of crisis so it's you know
we're still at the stage where it's very
very different from state to state I
mean the cat is kind of out of the bag
in certain states in Washington and in
New York but many other states still
have the opportunity to change their
fate so it's really a day-to-day battle
to make sure that we stay in the game
and that we we continue to be really
vigilant with all of our public health
measures or even escalate efforts so
that we can get over that hump and get
to the other side of this thing I mean
and that's it's amazing to hear that
things seem to be going really well or
going or doing much better and and you
know I'm curious I'm talking about those
other states that you mentioned that
maybe aren't faring as well I know
you're in touch with a lot of colleagues
in other parts of the country you know
what are you hearing from folks who are
maybe in some of those harder hit areas
yeah it's really unlike anything you've
seen I mean the thing to understand
about emergency care and disaster
response systems is this is what we do
you know it's not like we run on the
assumption of of normality you know we
we are always planning for the
worst-case scenario and so we're we're
prepared for disasters but but normal
quote-unquote normal disasters are
they're so much more contained than this
so you know we're ready for earthquakes
hurricanes other national natural
disasters or maybe a single mass
casualty all these things that have so
much more so many more sort of borders
to them you know these discrete events
maybe they affect a single city or a
region or you know you're in a position
where other states or regions can can
chip in I mean you've seen after some of
our largest disasters things like 9/11
other countries were so willing to sort
of lend a hand in terms of our our of
addressing our aftermath and and this is
one of those things where where should
the help be coming because we're all
dealing with this at the same time and
so everybody is either in full in it you
know like they are in New York City
either they're they're in there just
trying to deal with a huge caseload of
patients and then very sick patients and
just scrambling to be really creative
around these these limited resources
that we have everything from personal
protective equipment to the medications
and space and ventilators and healthcare
workers to just being in full-on
preparation mode and that's kind of
where we are right now in Oregon because
our our peak is expected to hit at the
end of April or early May and so we're
using that precious time to try to
figure out in every eventualities our
are we going to to handle this surge so
no matter what whether the wave has hit
or whether it's about to hit everyone is
really working 24/7 around this pandemic
and you know when I think about
emergency workers even before this time
you know I always think about them in
general just like a you know sort of
chaotic frantic space and you know I
have mentioned that that may change have
changed a little bit in the recent weeks
and so could you talk a little bit about
what your day-to-day experiences are
like now as compared to what they would
have been like what they were like
pre-pandemic yeah totally and again I'll
speak to the experiences of health care
workers that I'm hearing from everywhere
you know rather than just mine
individual er but there there's kind of
two parts to this one is in normal times
we run hospitals pretty lean you know so
we don't we don't run it so that you
walk into a shift and you're relaxing
for half of it you know or or so that we
have a bunch of empty beds just in case
I mean you run it to be pretty close to
maxed out all the time because we really
run it for financial efficiency you know
so hospitals more and more are very full
we're not expanding hospital wards we're
really running them as pretty close to
peak and in the emergency department I'm
on a regular day let's say a weekend
evening shift when when an ER doctor
walks in or an ER nurse walks in you
kind of stop and take this deep breath
because you know you're going to be
running non-stop basically all-out for
your entire shift eight to twelve hours
or whatever it is and so in normal
circumstances we are I mean you feel
pretty close to max capacity and then
add on to that a pandemic and you kind
of think of your worst regular day and
and in places where they've already hit
search it's twice regular or three times
or five times or ten times that and so
you went from it never was a relaxing
job I mean it was always a stressful job
where there's only so much one person
can do and yet you're doing more than
that all the time and just trying to
keep people safe - really - really you
know some order of magnitude higher than
that so places that are hit hard really
impossibly busy and then and then on the
flip side we are we have really done a
lot of work in terms of public messaging
and messaging through a health system
that if you are not very sick you should
stay away because first of all we need
to care for these kovat 19 patients and
also you don't want to get sick by
coming here because this is where the
Cova 19 patients are coming so for your
own safety and your family's safety
please stay away and so people even
people with very serious health
conditions are are staying away
and our caseload in the emergency room
is actually very different and so we're
disproportionately seeing patients who
have fever
you know respiratory illnesses symptoms
that are likely cope at 19 but almost
everything else has gone away or gone
down I think what else has contributed
to that is that with all of this social
distancing so people are staying at home
they're not going to parties or bars or
restaurants or places where you might
drink a lot and get into trouble
afterwards so a lot of that Friday night
Saturday night trauma that we would
normally normally see car accidents from
drunk driving or just from high traffic
conditions I mean all the things that
happen when you throw a whole bunch of
humans together in close quarters though
that is kind of our bread and butter in
the emergency room and we're not seeing
that whole chunk as much the puzzling
thing is actually why we're not seeing
things that have no relationship to Cove
in nineteen imeem heart attacks strokes
those diseases have not gotten any
notice that they should wait until kovat
is over you know and so where are those
diseases I mean there was an op-ed in
The New York Times the other day
wondering if people who have very
legitimate reasons to come into the
hospitals are also avoiding avoiding the
house but not that other things aren't
legitimate but you know things that that
are true emergencies that we should be
seen immediately otherwise can lead the
very poor outcomes or even death in a
short period of time what you know what
kind of collateral damage are we seeing
because people are afraid to come in so
but all of that adds up to a very
strange environment in the hospital
right now yeah I mean and that's and
that's so interesting to hear it sounds
like in some ways people are being
really more thoughtful about how when
they actually do need to seek out care
and when they can handle something
themselves and I and I imagine it
probably remains to be seen whether
that's better that people are dealing
with some things on their own at home or
or whether that's worse what is your
take on that probably a mix of both I
mean I think the truth is right in the
middle I think when we go back to normal
it's hard to imagine a time they'll come
back to normal but probably when we go
back to nor
we'll see some things we've learned can
stay out of the emergency room or you
know I think we're being very creative
about telehealth right now and I'm
getting people to get health care
through their computers or their phones
and I think we'll probably find that
that that we continue to have expanded
use of telemedicine after this because
it worked so well I bet people actually
be very happy and surprised by the
number of things that you can do at home
for some common health conditions but I
also think that when the surge is over
for every state we will get an influx of
those delayed care cases that will kind
of be the second surge of stress on the
healthcare system not directly rated
related to code 19 but what we're kind
of calling the collateral damage I'm
deferred health problems that really
could have benefited from an earlier
visit to the hospital emergency room or
and in-person visit to your doc to your
doctor or nurse practitioner or whoever
and you know as the months have gone on
and you know we've been dealing with
this as a country as a world you know
for these past few months in emergency
rooms in your emergency room how have
you seen the situation change or worsen
you know how are things different now
than they were say back in early
February I mean now we are in it I mean
all of us to some extent I mean it's hit
all 50 states and so it went from this
anticipation to really needing to make
those hard decisions and I mean this is
so challenging always but in this
disease we're not familiar with it and
so we are learning on the fly so we're
learning from China from Italy from
South Korea and then from our own early
States but that decision making changes
so fast that that really there are some
days where I feel like the hospital I
walk out of at the end of my shift is
different than the hospital I walk into
at the beginning of my shift and I'm
hearing this from colleagues all over
the place it's not just at my
institution where people are sitting you
know we've created these these COBIT
emergency task force or committees that
make decisions for for every health
system
and people are sitting and receiving
data as it rolls in and then using that
data to enrich the response in their own
institution so whether it's I'm trying
to think of a good example like even
just what we decide to do around brown
face masks or around how we manage
certain types of patients what
medications were looking at as potential
therapies I mean this is how wild and
and quick it is a few weeks ago earlier
in this pandemic we were concerned about
a certain class of blood pressure
medication called AR B's angiotensin
receptor blockers and the rumor was that
these were harmful that these would
actually lead to more severe disease and
there was a question about whether we
should be taking patients off of those
medications who are using them for blood
pressure control 3 weeks later that
medication is being used in the hospital
as a potential therapy I mean that is
how fast a science is changing it was it
was bad
now it's potentially really good I mean
I it's a constant process of keeping up
with what the best evidence is telling
us is right to do and I mean I'll just
tell you you're always wondering am I
getting it wrong right now as I feel
like it's gonna be different in about 24
hours and you just do the best that you
can with with current information well I
mean - you've been documenting your
experiences and uh sort of talking about
what how you've been going through this
pandemic and your new podcast doctor's
log and you know you've talked about
some of the unique challenges that
health workers are facing one of those
being heightened exposure to the virus
and so I'd love to talk about that a
little bit just you know what are some
of the physical ways what does the
physical toll that this pandemic is
having on health workers yeah this is
this is so stressful I mean we are used
to working under conditions where your
risk is some nonzero number above that
of the general population you know we
see dangerous infections all the time
there is violence in the health care
works the workplace because of the
volatility of what we see all the time
and so there's a little bit of you know
adrenaline there that's that's always
present and that we we're used to over
time you actually become completely a
nerd to some of these things that aren't
a part of other people's day-to-day
existence but with this we have a you
know a disease that's highly
transmissible and also is is leads to
very severe disease and so you know and
then you throw in there the shortage of
this one simple resource which is this
personal protective equipment and when
you put those three things together and
we're seeing a high volume of patients
it's you know it's it really becomes
stressful on a different level because
it's rare that we see something in the
hospital where we have to worry what am
i bringing home to my family member
because I wasn't perfectly protected
against this very dangerous disease and
I think when you add on that layer of
personal stress all the time am i right
by doing this thing that I love to do
care for patients am I putting my family
at risk
am i putting other patients at risk my
colleagues at risk I think that has been
one of the most emotionally draining
things of this of this whole pandemic is
just not just not being free to kind of
go in and just do your clinical duty to
the top of your potential but having
this added layer of of constant stress
about how much you're able to do it
safely yeah I mean it's seeing these
headlines really across the world about
the number of health workers who
contract the virus and you know that
sort of thing is is is really upsetting
and you know thank you doctor true for
all you do and I think another thing
that you talk about you know and also
thinking about you mentioned not having
PPE but also other equipment that we've
seen a lot in the headlines that are
we're lacking in the hospitals are
shortage of our ventilators
you've talked about this and how it's
not just enough to think about the
ventilators themselves but you know what
are some other factors that we need to
consider when we're thinking about the
need for ventilators in in medical
centers and hospitals yeah the the needs
are so great and it's really everything
that you know it's everything that
surrounds the ventilator you know it's
it none of these things live in
isolation you know and so when I think
of just the issue of the ventilator um
that we're running out of it's like well
you you actually need highly trained
staff to use a ventilator it's not like
you can just take anybody and just put
them next to a ventilator and they can
start programming it in this super fancy
you know with with all skill and
confidence you know we we rely on the
fact that there's a highly trained
workforce including respiratory
therapists intensive care unit trained
specifically trained physicians nurses
who are really experienced in ICU care
even to put somebody on a ventilator you
need a number of common medications just
a date and paralyze them so that they
can tolerate the insertion of a pretty
rigid plastic tube down their throat and
then to keep them in a state that's
comfortable so that they can stay on
that tube for many many days which is a
very uncomfortable thing actually and so
you know and so we need all of those
medications and we need them in pretty
large quantities and then of course you
know ventilators need to go into
intensive care units those intensive
care units require a lot of maintenance
I mean the cleaning staff to to clean a
intensive care unit where there's been a
kovat positive patient in these our
larger rooms they have a lot of
equipment in it often the cleaning after
a Koba 19 patient to do it right and
disinfect that space so it's safe for
the next patient that's an hour and
twenty to thirty minute process or more
depending on the facility so or that
that room is just out of use and so I
mean there really is a complex team that
it takes in order to maintain an
intensive care unit around a single
machine it's really hard to to convey
that all the time you know it's a lot
easier to say we need the single
resource let's manufacture it and get it
there and I will say to just this this
whole thing is really such an education
on public health messaging and how we
get ordinary people and policymakers to
kind of get galvanized around some of
these issues that are buried deep within
a hospital it's like the deeper you get
into a hospital and the further you get
from outside of it the harder it is to
communicate these needs and so you know
testing was something that was very
relatable to people and that we were
really able to raise public outrage
about because everybody suddenly wanted
to get tested right I mean you had a
virus the the the the Cova 19 disease
was in the country you wanted to know
whether you had it and so if you didn't
then something you knew really wanted
that test PPE the personal protective
equipment that was a little harder
that's the first step into the hospital
what do you need if you're working on
copa90 and you need some PPE and so and
there was something so visual about it
right we saw pictures of healthcare
workers with their masks and their
goggles and their gowns and and we saw
those images from other countries where
they were wearing them or not wearing
them you see the pictures on one of the
most vivid pictures I think that will
remain in people's memories after this
is the pictures of the health care
workers with the bruises around their
faces for wearing these masks non-stop
because normally we don't always wear
personal protective equipment for every
single patient but having to wear it for
patient after patient for hundreds of
patients over a shift people started to
get bruising on their faces and there
was something so visual and visceral and
relatable about that and so we got
people really excited about PPE and I'm
so glad because I think we won't get
relief in those in that resource soon
after that our ability to kind of
communicate our needs are as critical as
they are they may be as critical as PPE
and as testing once you get downstream
to a stage of disease where you need to
be treated in the hospital it's very
hard to communicate how badly we need
these things and get the kind of you
know the public interest and an outrage
and energy around it but really every
single thing that we need in the
hospital is is we're starting to strain
the supply I'd love to
I fell in here yeah yeah please Helen so
many questions pouring into Facebook so
I'll just share a couple and then I'll
jump back off but I think overwhelming
made the number one question that people
have is how can they help alright I'm
sorry that question just kind of kills
me it kills me every time and you think
I'd be ready for it because how many
people are asking me so Oh give me a
second first of all everyone who asked
that question thank you I mean we feel
feel the outpouring of goodwill and and
I mean that is honestly what keeps us
going to work every single day and gives
us energy to do this and it actually it
makes me feel like how can I do more so
thank you and I will say there there are
a million ways to help I'll throw it a
couple of simple things the first of all
whatever you do to help your own
community helps us so even if you're not
out there I mean a lot of people are
selling face masks and things are
contributing to you know to the to
increasing the supply of PPE and that's
wonderful but but it doesn't have to be
that literal so when you contribute to
your local food bank your local homeless
or domestic violence shelter your local
diaper bank in any way contributing to
the needs of the community around here
you are helping us and I will tell you
even in times of pandemic we are seeing
people come to the hospital because they
are lacking food and they are lacking
shelter because those needs are still
paramount for people and so when you
help in those ways that is healthcare
that you are giving directly and you are
helping us every single day keep people
healthy so those things are so valuable
I think the second thing is to come into
the healthcare mentality which is that
this is not going to be short it is
going to be prolonged and there is no
single campaign that will win this thing
they're going to be many campaigns after
campaigns and I always feel like I'm
giving bad news but I want people to
kind of spread the word that this needs
to be a really sustained effort we don't
have an end date we may even have a
second surge of disease on particularly
if you don't get this right we don't
have a timing for things like vaccines
and effective treatments those things
simply take time so I would say take the
little breaks that you need to from
you're helping roll help when you have
the energy and you know and the
resources to do so but also take time
for yourself but understand that this is
not going to be short and then the last
thing I would say is remember that
sometimes what we don't do is as
important as what we do do and so people
are always worried that they haven't
done enough but remember that restraint
is so important here and one example
I'll give is every time there's a whiff
of promise around a medication people
are going out and they are they are
trying to get people to prescribe it to
them they're they're filling these
prescriptions and in quantities that are
much higher than than anybody needs and
really there's some medication hoarding
that's going on so I would ask people
you know wait for the evidence and the
recommendations please let health
professionals guide how we use these
resources and and please don't do the
toilet-paper thing for any resource in
healthcare we need to we need to have
enough restraint that the limited
resources we have yet to those who
really need them that goes for a number
of things also those you know hi Phil
tration facemasks some people in the
public do not need to be wearing those
and those should go directly to health
care workers one of the question and
then I'll jump back into the comments
but even there's a question around the
risk of using a drug for something it
wasn't intended and I guess this is a
reference to Cora Queen which has become
a kind of a word that non-medical
professionals are now using liberally
but what do you make of the kind of the
sudden resurgence of people's awareness
and knowledge of chloroquine and what
should we actually think about it yeah
there you know every time there is a
pandemic there are a number of
medications that have the
radical benefit because they have in
vitro action against against the virus
and there have been many disappointments
I mean all all these medications that
we're talking about hydrochloric win and
as if through Meissen and antivirals
that are effective against different
viruses we wonder can it work against
this virus maybe the excitement about
these medications hydroxychloroquine i
think is the one that's been mentioned
the most I mean really through the roof
I'm excited too it would be nice to know
if it works we have very little data on
these we have not been able to do these
randomized control trials that will
allow us to know not only are they
effective but is the is the good that
they're doing does it exceed the harms
because all these medications have
potential toxicity on you know they have
psychiatric side effects they have
cardio toxicity particularly in
combination with other medications that
affect your heart they can cause very
serious illness seizures and even death
and we've seen we've seen an early death
from from the use of chloroquine so so a
lot of caution here in every sense there
is no indication for people to go out
and start using these medications as
either prophylaxis or treatment I'm
really worried about how people can hurt
themselves and advertently particularly
if they're taking these outside the
recommendation of a health professional
I mean that's just a nightmare waiting
to happen and I'll also say I mean this
goes in line with with the issue of
medication shortages but I mean the the
treatment for hydroxychloroquine or
chloroquine overdoses is is generally
benzodiazepines which is another
medication that we're in very short
supply of we need critically for
intensive care unit patients and so you
know everything has consequences that we
will then have to grapple with so not
you know unsupported you so these
medications this really has the
potential to be another disaster buried
within this disaster we do not want that
okay I'm jumping off thank you so much
back to you Whitney
Helen you know it's so you talked about
sort of how you've been advocating for
PPE and our need for that and you
advocate for a lot of things in this
public health space that I think are
just really critically important at this
time and one of those things is the work
that you're doing with chip health and
I'd love to talk a little bit about that
as far as looking at building emergency
health centers and creating these spaces
at this time and as we're seeing that
hospitals are overcrowded throughout the
country the world you know I guess how
how long before we get to a point where
where we really are beyond capacity and
and need to seek out alternative
measures yeah we're already seeing it in
New York and I think we will actually
see this space shortage in every major
city and then a different kind of space
shortage actually in rural and critical
access areas so you know in large cities
we're running out of space in every
single cup you know if every single kind
so yes it is the intensive care units
and it's the hospital wards and it's a
space in the emergency department and
you've seen these I think you've seen
these pictures in in emergency medicine
triage where people packed in there like
sardines no doubt transmitting disease
while they're waiting you know and so
some hospitals are bumping out to large
tents places where they can enforce try
to enforce social distancing while
people are waiting to be seen some of
them very sick but there's also housing
needs around health care so increasingly
as we're seeing many many very static
Ovid patients and particularly when you
add in that layer of inadequate PPE our
personal protective equipment um health
care workers are not wanting to go home
and that's a very reasonable thing to
watch because we we want to we want to
shield our families as we do this I mean
a number of many many health care
workers I know are sick and have to go
into quarantine away from their families
and so where do we do that I mean
hospitals are only equipped to handle a
very small handful of health care
workers spending the night you know so
you go into any hospital in a regular
time in the
they're empty at night and you just have
a tiny handful of physicians who are
required to stay in house overnight this
is to sleep there you know between
between daytime hours and so you'll have
a couple of call rooms and now we have
this this situation where a large
portion of our healthcare staff does not
want to go home in between and so we're
getting really generous offers I mean in
the in New York City for example the
Four Seasons offered its hotel rooms up
to up to health care workers who wanted
to stay there to keep their families
safe or to avoid the commute between
shifts and that's great but you know
most hospitals aren't lucky enough to be
next door to a luxury hotel where they
can spend a month and so how are we
pumping out housing in addition to all
the health care space we need and and so
that's why I started working with this
amazing team it's a project called Joop
health and we're building three kinds of
units as fast as we can so this this
expanded housing for health care workers
and actually for other people who have
covin 19 or likely have codon koba 19
and cannot go back to their their living
situation for whatever reasons so you
think of people living in homeless
shelters domestic violence shelters
group homes nursing homes correctional
facilities psychiatric units basically
all these places that we're calling
coronavirus traps because people are
held in there there is no option for
social distancing and the infection is
spreading like wildfire fire unless we
take known cases and actually pull them
out so expanded housing can be used for
any of those populations and then basic
hospital beds and then and then actually
these these mobile intensive care units
that are being designed with
architecture design teams engineering
teams and a whole bunch of health
professionals and also patients and
patient advocates and we're trying to
make a very functional space that can be
shipped anywhere in the United States
very quickly there are hospitals in
remote areas that don't have hundreds of
ICU beds that they can mobilize they
might have two ICU
but all of a sudden they're not able to
transfer all the kovat patients that
they need to take care of and so we want
to see that their needs as well as we
see that the needs of people and very
densely populated areas that simply
don't have room I mean I think the
reality is we can't you know we can't
run hospitals that have have endless
capacity for surge I mean that's just
not something that you can build and
maintain so what are creative ways we
can we can do this we can create very
deployable extra space not just for this
crisis but but for every single other
one that we face moving forward and you
know when you think about these needs
for health workers and and just for the
broader community you know how much of
this is on the government and I you know
and I'm curious to hear I guess what you
feel like in thinking about this crisis
what the government has getting right
both on the federal state level and then
what are some of the areas that really
still need more attention yeah I mean I
I think it's pretty fair to say that the
government response as a whole has been
disappointing
the biggest tragedy is that when that's
those first cases came in the United
States that we didn't get on top of the
testing that day not even that day the
month before when we knew that this was
starting to spread and it was clear this
was going to be a global pandemic it
really I find it hard to even think
about because I it's so upsetting that
we didn't just roll out testing encase
and contact identification very
assertively from the beginning I mean
that was the difference between what
will ultimately be hundreds of thousands
of lives lost and and and having saved
all those lives will be that early thing
and you know you're psychologically it's
so bad to dwell I'm trying not to dwell
on that first mistake but and really
just kind of move forward and say okay
how do we avoid that that that
and that's kind of been where I'm trying
to push the conversation like okay
what's the next thing you know it's like
okay we're kind of got behind testing we
still aren't where we need to be with
testing but then then what you know what
are the other containment measures and
then when we get to the you know
downstream to the treatment everything's
really about containment and then
treatment capacity and I I think
containment is where I really wanted to
focus and then it was like okay well we
because we failed in containment we
better shift quickly and think about
here escalation so how do we expand our
care capacity and it's sad to me that's
that's where I need to be but since
we're going to be doing large-scale care
what are all the little gaps that we
need to fill so and I think the really
hard thing I mean I've been involved in
in these organizations to try to improve
our PPE supply and the and I can you
know we're all so many hundreds of
thousands of people are involved in this
and and I think we're able to boost
supply here and there and and have have
some successes but what we can't do what
is very hard to do on the grassroots
level is to centralize our understanding
of the problem I mean there should be in
an ideal world a national command center
that has its fingers on the pulse across
all 50 states that knows where are all
of our hospitals and health systems and
clinics what are their patient caseloads
like and what do they need of every
single resource whether it's human
resources or or these concrete sees
these recent these supply resources and
then understands the national supply and
can divert resources exactly where they
need to go at the exact right time
including identifying places that are
getting over the you know the surge and
are able to reallocate to other places
where they're just entering their surge
so that kind of centralized national
coordinating role is something that
we're really missing here
and I think not only does it make it
hard for all of us to get the resources
we need but there's real equity issues
here I
worried all the time about who is
getting the limited resources it's
probably they're really enriched out
systems that have a lot of political
power in their communities and you know
have already we're kind of well
resourced going in they're likely to get
more and smaller and less resource
places are simply not going to get the
attention the political will the the
voice do to get what they need and that
affects their their communities and so
there's there's huge inequities that are
going to be doubled down because we
don't have a coordinated system that
that has some you know some structure in
place to make sure these decisions and
resources are equitably made Helen has
some got some more questions from online
I do I have overweening love for you and
gratitude but everything that you're
doing and I have some questions too so
one is someone has five and ninety five
masks they want to donate them but
they're not quite sure how to do that
how how can how can they help how can
they get those masks to you or to your
colleagues thank you
so most hospitals have listed drop-off
locations for n95 and ours and actually
have built methods for people to be able
to drive by not get out of your car and
risk yourself by coming into a health
care center but to be able to do it on
the outside with minimal contact and so
I would encourage you to to either call
your local hospital or health system
almost everybody has a kovat hotline set
up or the hospital operator can divert
you to it also if you go on some of
these coordinating websites the one I'm
involved with is called get us PPE org
we have by state a sorted list of
hospitals that are accepting PPE
donations including the address and
hours of drop-off so you can go right
there and hopefully find one that's
close to you and then this is arguably a
more personal question so apologies in
advance but we've seen a really shocking
rise in anti-asian discrimination
through this and I just wonder what
message you have for pew
or who are turning inwards or who are
allowing their fear and anger to turn
outwards to another to another group if
you have any words of wisdom on that
yeah this is this is another one of
those collateral damage pieces that is
so disturbing with this virus I mean the
virus from the minute we were aware of
it came along with racism and hatred and
I am a part of many Asian American
communities and I mean the stories are
not mine to tell but I will tell you
that people have had very harrowing
harrowing experiences directed at them
and that their young children that are
clearly linked to fear of kovat 19
because you know people will explicitly
say things that that relate to the virus
and and why they're people brought it
into this country and it's a it's a
terrible time and I don't know what
advice I have except that we should all
be aware that it's happening I have a
number of friends who said I didn't see
it until you pointed it out and now it's
it's terribly obvious and so I think we
all I think just acknowledging it when
you see it even though you're not the
target of it being really explicit that
this is not acceptable right now I think
people being the best allies they can be
because very hard in the moment when
you're experiencing that kind of racism
to stand up for yourself or for your
family members so I think this is one of
those times where we really need people
to call it out and to tamp it down
quickly where they see it happening well
sit I mean it's at this point of
collateral damage I know that you've
also talked to about some of the other
downstream medical effects that you've
seen that are not even connected to
people contracted the virus at all you
know you've talked about domestic
violence and I'd love to hear you I
guess address that a little bit more
just what what are you seeing as it
relates to those sorts of issues yeah
this is one thing that's again been
traveling around my community my online
communities of physicians and nurse
is and this is only anecdotal now I
don't have the data but I think it will
come as we as we look back but when you
put people into their homes 24/7 and and
when you do that in a very economically
stressful time where people are losing
their jobs and feeling a lot of stress
about just getting meals on the table I
mean that is a setting in which in which
family violence child abuse into their
partner violence will increase and we're
seeing that in the hospital I mean I've
seen a number of cases where people fled
to the hospital because their home was
simply not safe and became abruptly more
not safe because of stay at home orders
I've seen young children harmed because
in their regular lives they could escape
to school for a good chunk of the day or
they had these extended communities of
family members and friends floating
around and then stay at home orders went
to place and everybody retreated into
their homes and there was no that
barrier that always was the difference
between safety and harm was suddenly
removed and family violence went up and
and truly I mean I am a violence
researcher I'm always very attuned to
the patients who come in who are
experiencing violence and I have never
seen anything like this before and and I
think you will never attach a cope of 19
diagnosis to this know no review of
medical records may really may really
attach this to cope in nineteen but I
consider this a very a very sad part of
the collateral damage that's happening
directly because of this disease
and you know as we wrap up here I think
I'm sure that this is something that a
lot of folks out there are thinking
about too is just you know what is I
guess the the big takeaway what are the
the big things that we should know that
we should do the ensure that we can get
to what is whatever the best case
scenario is at this point yeah well I
would say to to give people a measure of
hope and optimism your little actions
are working so I know there's nothing
glamorous about do nothing and
at home and I am so acutely aware of how
much people are sacrificing I mean
people are they're sacrificing their
businesses their livelihood people who
are just on the edge of being a feeling
financially secure are just giving it
all up to stay at home you couldn't ask
for a bigger sacrifice and yet those
things are working look at what's
happening in Ohio in Oregon in other
states where we're really able to get
ahead of this we are protecting
ourselves our family members and also
importantly our really vulnerable
members of society are our older
citizens by doing these things and doing
that sacrifice so I think while we're
going through some really really tough
times in these hardest hit cities what
we're what everyday people are doing in
response is really working so I think it
can feel futile I think sometimes to
just kind of sit quietly and do your
social distancing thing and nobody you
know there's no glory in that and it's
also can be incredibly boring I'm
learning looking online and seeing how
creative people are getting with their
dance moves and their bread recipes but
it really is also heroic work and it is
saving lives for sure so thank you to
everybody for for that simple act it's
making everything better well thank you
dr. chu I think I speak for everyone and
how how much we appreciate you coming
spending time with us today
sharing your experiences and your wisdom
and knowledge Helen did you have any
last things that you wanted to share
only that it's kind of you to try and
deflect but we all know who the heroes
are around here and it's it's pretty
okay to be able to sit on the sofa and
watch TV so thank you for everything
that you're doing and just the deepest
appreciation and gratitude from
everybody who's been watching from
everyone its head in from hell I'll
speak for everyone in the world thank
you so much thank you dr. chu